grazie molte signore e signori sono
molto contento di essere qui con voi io
ho seguito
tutte le i dibattiti di questa mattina
con grande interesse sono
particolarmente felice di essere qui con
voi questo pomeriggio e potermi
interfacciare in questa maniera con voi
perché solitamente la mia percezione del
pubblico è questa
io il pubblico cielo sempre alle spalle
il mio ai contact è costantemente con
l'orchestra un co i cantanti sul
palcoscenico quindi questo pomeriggio
lungi dal darvi le spalle voglio
abbattere questo che solitamente viene
avvertito dal pubblico meno avvezzo ai
concerti sinfonici all'opera o alla
musica classica più in generale come un
vero e proprio muro una barriera verso
un intero universo musicale e vorrei
condividere oggi alcuni pensieri alcune
riflessioni che ho maturato in questi
anni ormai di attività professionale
musicale e che spero potranno essere
utili non solo a chi si dedica alla
musica o alla divulgazione musicale ma
più in generale a chi si interroga oggi
sul rapporto tra modernità tra presente
e ciò che ci ha preceduto la grande
cultura la grande arte e tutto ciò che
viene oggi
chiamato con quel nome che vuol dire
tutto e niente con la tradizione se
siamo tutti quanti dei nanetti sulle
spalle di grandi giganti e vero dobbiamo
guardare al futuro ma dobbiamo capire
soprattutto da dove veniamo e che cosa
di quello che ci viene insegnato e ci è
stato insegnato nel passato può essere
applicabile ad oggi io sono un direttore
d'orchestra e la mia attività musicale
prevalentemente è nel campo di quella
che viene etichettata da oggi giorno con
una parola che io detesto cioè musica
classica e che evoca immediatamente
soprattutto nei nel pubblico di più
giovani delle nuove generazioni di
ascoltatori un'immediata repulsione
tanto quanto la crea in me musica
classica è un termine innanzi tutto
improprio che evoca immediatamente
l'idea del museo di quei personaggi
incidentati di cui rimane solo il busto
un po impolverati anche è un qualcosa
che non ha rapporti col presente ma che
soprattutto come dicevo è un termine
improprio musica classica delimita e
etichetta un periodo molto preciso della
storia della musica che va grosso modo
dalla fine del seicento alla fine del
settecento mentre invece oggi musica
classica è una parola calderone dove si
butta dentro in maniera indistinta
praticamente tutto quello che è musica
colta musica d'arte musica da concerto
quindi musica sinfonica musica da camera
finanche l'opera lirica che di per sé
proprio col termine musica classica poco
a che fare e quindi sicuramente è un
termine che mette soggezione e paura
soprattutto nei giovani me ne accorgo
spesso parlando e cercando di
confrontarmi con le giovani generazioni
di ascoltatori e l'approccio che
immagino la gran parte di voi abbia
avuto con questa che per comodità
chiameremo musica classica ha sempre i
tratti del trauma infantile molto spesso
perché non
tutti hanno la fortuna come io ho avuto
di nascere in una famiglia dove la
musica classica era molto ascoltata
molto importante così come l'opera
lirica mia madre già 23 anni mi faceva
giocare con i tasti del pianoforte a 34
anni mi facevano sentire il don giovanni
di mozart ora mia madre una grande donna
forse un pochino estrema nei suoi metodi
didattico pedagogici ma insomma è stato
sicuramente una ricchezza che mi ha dato
anche se non me ne sono accorto
immediatamente ma per la maggior parte
credo di voi e delle persone che sono
qui in generale maggior parte delle
persone italiane il primo contatto con
la musica classica avviene nel periodo
scolastico soprattutto nei primi anni
della scuola dove ora io non voglio
assolutamente prendere questo palco per
criticare il metodo dell'educazione
italiana anche perché una volta hanno
fatto sui permettendomi di dissentire
sull'uso dei flauti dolci di plastica
che tutti voi avete e sono stato
massacrato dalla maggior parte
dei docenti italiani no
ma non per non per attaccare gli
insegnanti minimamente anzi gli
insegnanti di musica soprattutto
italiani fanno una fatica tremenda e
devono fronteggiare
migliaia di difficoltà quindi a volte
l'unica cosa che hanno il frutto dolce
ma fare musica con un pezzo di plastica
trovato come sorpresa nell'uovo di
pasqua io trovo sia un pochino
controproducente e quindi il più delle
volte la musica classica e questo
mattone di cultura con la c maiuscola
che viene scagliata in testa ai
ragazzini un po quando 16 ragazzini non
studiano top run di dante tolstoj lo
tirano in testa chiaramente non si
calibra e non si crea un contatto tra un
qualcosa di estremamente ricco e
importante è una personalità dall'altra
parte ancora magari informazione che ha
bisogno di linee guida all'interno di
questo panorama io ho fatto ho cercato
di fare mini al a causa della
divulgazione musicale proprio perché ho
visto della difficoltà
in italia di comunicare i grandi
contenuti della musica della nostra
tradizione dell'opera della musica
sinfonica della musica da camera ai
giovani ascoltatori e proprio perché nel
momento in cui un'istituzione come la
scuola con mille difficoltà economiche
fa fatica a offrire ai giovani
un'opportunità di approcciarsi a questo
genere ecco che allora credo sia dovere
di noi
interpreti scendere per una volta dal
podio abbattere la barriera delle spalle
girate verso il pubblico e cercare di
dialogare e di costruire un'offerta di
contenuti che noi reputiamo estremamente
affascinanti e interessanti
creando però dei punti in comune fra voi
e noi che studiamo queste cose tutto il
giorno e vai chiaramente abbiamo un
approccio differente a a questa materia
ecco che allora il dialogo che io spesso
instaura soprattutto con i
ragazzi più giovani che vengono a
sentire queste mie introduzione alla
musica classica e che ho cominciato devo
dire con grande soddisfazione a fare
anche durante i concerti che tengo e con
ottimi risultati devo dire si basa
sempre su cercare di relazionare quello
che io faccio al mondo soprattutto
interiore di chi mi sta ascoltando a
poche persone interessa se la prima
volta che mette piede in una sala da
concerto che la sinfonia di beethoven
che stiamo eseguendo sia all'interno di
un panorama storico culturale bla bla
bla interessa capire primariamente io
credo che cosa questo brano che arriva
da secoli di distanza da me a
regalarmi ha da dirmi oggi quindi vorrei
farvi ascoltare un frammento di musica
così lo commentiamo insieme regole gen
è nata bene
grazie tutti avrete probabilmente
riconosciuto l'incipit l'inizio della
famosissima quinta sinfonia di beethoven
questi lavori classici bene o male tutti
gli abbiamo sentiti o nelle pubblicità o
nel film con il cane san bernardo
ma sono diventati un po come la gioconda
91 vede la gioconda diceva che palle
cioè il magnete sul frigo pazienza se
bello però invece una volta mi sono
riferito a questo lavoro parlando
proprio con dei ragazzi l'ho anche
scritto nel mio libro non è musica per
vecchi
che il messaggio di questa sinfonia è
paragonabile per esempio a una canzone
degli acdc band rock non mi piace
particolarmente e ragazzi subito ci sono
rimasti così perché sentono un universo
sonoro che sembra distante dal nostro
dalle chitarre elettriche dalla batteria
ma in realtà il messaggio che
condividono magari una una canzone di
questo gruppo con questa sinfonia è
assolutamente il medesimo e attraversa i
secoli lancia un ponte passa attraverso
quella barriera del tempo e arriva
direttamente nei nostri cuori perché voi
sapete io penso tutti noi siamo un po
delle isole siamo delle entità a sé
stanti delle
delle monadi non molla del veronese
un'altra cosa
dell'entità singole che fanno magari
anche fatica a dialogare a volte quindi
come faccio io a sapere che la tua gioia
e la mia gioia che la tua tristezza e la
mia tristezza io credo che la musica
come l'arte in generale ma la musica in
particolare sia fondamentale per questo
processo
riconoscersi in quanto esseri umani nel
condividere emozioni che dalla musica
possono essere sottolineate in maniera
assolutamente forte e indelebile ed ecco
che allora una sinfonia scritta
nel 1800 e 8
diventa si lancia attraverso i secoli e
porta un messaggio che noi possiamo
riconoscere come nostro la rabbia di un
beethoven che scrive in un'europa
tormentata da un lato dalla rivoluzione
francese fallita dall'altra dalla
restaurazione da tensioni sociali enormi
grida ci grida in faccia con una
sinfonia voi pensate le sinfonie
classiche questa volta il termine giusto
del settecento erano lavori scritti
essenzialmente per i nobili che si
dovranno divertire mentre mangiavano in
sottofondo c'era un po di musica di
haydn c'era un po di musica di mozart
beethoven arriva e scardina questo
meccanismo lui non ha nemmeno saltato il
muro lui la sfondato come un autotreno
impazzito ha spalancato le porte della
sala da concerto infrangendole e ha
portato una carica emotiva
straordinaria e rabbiosa derivata dal
basso non dalla cultura elitaria da le
opere teoriche dei grandi maestri del
passato ma derivata dal fermento che si
sentiva nelle strade ed ecco che allora
questa musica suona veramente come un
inno alla ribellione all'affermazione
più spudorata dell'individuo e della sua
libertà
e non è forse
contenuto che possiamo ritrovare in
tantissime canzoni del rock nelle grandi
canzoni dei nostri canti autori italiane
così come tanti altri messaggi
ovviamente anche più positivi più
costruttivi ma ecco che invitò vena
allora non c'è più l'immaginetta del
mezzobusto che scrive
sinfonie antiche polverose lui la
parrucca queste cose qui abbiamo un
interlocutore
estremamente moderno e che ci dice
qualcosa ora questo ovviamente non è
facile per noi musicisti
classici di oggi siamo un pochettino
dovete sapere ingabbiati in una routine
artistica e che non sempre ci aiuta a
dialogare con chi viene nella sala da
concerto del resto il concerto stesso la
formula del concerto sinfonico ad
esempio non è cambiato di una virgola
dal xix secolo quando è stato inventato
voi vedete l'orchestra michetta si
accorda dopodiché tutti in silenzio e
vanno giu le luci entra il direttore
stringe la mano al primo violino se ha
voglia fa un inchino a voi se no si gira
tanto poi c'è la porsche che lo aspetta
fuori non è il mio caso però c'è anche
chi lo fa il suo concerto e buonanotte
dando per scontato che tutti i messaggi
contenuti nella musica siano appannaggio
di tutti quanti ovviamente i tempi
cambiano
siamo nell'era di internet delle musiche
incrociate io vado su you tube o la
possibilità di ascoltare quanti genere
musicale un'infinita da quelli scritti
inventati ieri alle musiche che ne so
giavanesi del xii secolo a tutto il
repertorio classico quindi c'è anche
confusione ea volte tutti questi generi
si mescolano in una strana musica
di oggi ma dove è difficile fermarsi e
cogliere il senso di ogni linguaggio ed
ecco che quindi io ritengo sfida per
chiunque si dedichi a un'arte
proveniente dal passato alla cultura che
ci ha preceduto se la vogliamo appunto
portare all gli altri dobbiamo scendere
dal piedistallo anche se sappiamo molto
non possiamo permetterci di rivolgerci
con superiorità delle nostre conoscenze
da persone che magari si approcciano
anche con con curiosità ma che vengano
immediatamente frustrate da una distanza
di chi propone anche contenuti
importanti a me piace molto parlare di
musica anche se frank zappa diceva che
parlare di musica che come ballare di
architettura che è proprio vero la
musica o si ascolta così fa e si cerca
di gioirne però mi piace farmi delle
domande interrogarmi né dialogare con
voi e quindi dopo interminabili
discussioni dove si condivide il proprio
pensiero riguardo appunto la musica rock
degli anni 70 alla musica folk irlandese
a gli one direction pure perché voglio
dire parafrasando la frase dei filosofi
classici io sono un musicista e non
ritengo alieno da me nulla che sia
musica e quindi tutto mi interessa mi
interessa tutto il panorama di oggi ma
immediatamente quando si arriva a
parlare di musica classica
c'è questo timore reverenziale a no ma
io non sono un esperto
no io sono non l'ascolto tanto o la più
terribile io non ho orecchio
signori tutti avete orecchie la musica
scorre in noi abbiamo parlato tutta la
mattina di circolarità c'è un ritmo
nelle stagioni nel mondo c'è il ritmo
dentro di noi c'è un cuore che batte e
se non aveste orecchie non sapreste
distinguere un napoletano da un veronese
quando parlano quello e l'orecchio
musicale tutti ce l'abbiamo quindi credo
che compito per appunto il 2000 di noi
che facciamo cultura sia portare
prendere per mano il pubblico che
abbiamo di fronte e cercare di
introdurli attraverso questo
parallelismo che ho cercato molto
velocemente di farvi vedere su un piano
emotivo che tutti condividiamo e cercare
questi link dall'oggi a ieri alla grande
musica che ci ha preceduto e senza la
quale oggi non avremmo questa questo
panorama è difficile io per primo trovo
grandi difficoltà però ho cercato di
fare la mia parte sono qui che parlo con
voi come tra qualche giorno sarò tra le
scuole come vi ho detto faccio precedere
quasi sempre i miei concerti da delle
introduzioni perché il programma di sala
scritto dal musicologo il 70 per cento
del pubblico e l'ho chiesto fatti
sondaggi non lo legge ma giustamente
perché viene presentato tutto come
qualcosa di distante da ignorante
vergognati se non sai quante cantate ha
scritto johann sebastian bach si può
anche essere però non credo sia questo
l'approccio ho scritto un libro tanto
per il fatto che parlare di musica come
ballare di architettura ho scritto un
libro dedicato a questi temi che se
avrete la bontà e l'interesse di leggere
mi fate contento si chiama non è musica
per vecchi ed è edito da rizzoli ed è
esplicito specificamente dedicato agli
ascoltatori di domani dove accanto
alla descrizione di brani musicali o di
come funziona la musica il dietro le
quinte abbiamo dei cure cod che
inquadrati con il cellulare possono far
sentire in presa diretta il brano di cui
si sta discutendo
questa è la sfida credo per gli artisti
per chi si occupa di cultura trovare il
meglio dell'oggi per coinvolgere
dapprima sul piano emotivo è un primo
step e poi magari sempre più in
profondità
il pubblico voi ma soprattutto il
pubblico che verrà perché la musica
classica per sopravvivere deve trovare
una nuova linfa dalla modernità e così
saremmo veramente dei nanetti che
diventano magari un po più grandi e
chiudiamo con beethoven che dire è la
cosa migliore grazie a tutti